It's pretty hot.
Pretty hot?
No one else had to say it.
It's pretty hot.
Good evening!
Hi.
All of you in the room.
All of you tuning in on
line.
Welcome.
My name is Erin Minor,
pronoun she, her.
I am so glad you're here tonight.
You are here on an extra special night
because it is our
sixth anniversary of being a church.
We started in November
2019,
which was right before the pandemic
hit.
We were a church for a few months
and then we had to go online only
for a while.
I like to call us the little church that could
because we made it through that.
I feel like if we can make it through a global pandemic,
we can make it through anything.
The church is nothing without
the people.
Thank you so much to those that have joined
us along the way, those who have
been with us since the beginning.
Those who have given of their time
and their energy and their resources to be
part of this community.
It matters. It makes a difference.
There aren't many churches like ours in this area.
It's necessary.
It's important. It is life-saving.
Thank you so much for being a part of it.
It's a big deal.
Just a few announcements
before we get into worship tonight.
It's been a while since I've done this,
so pardon my...
I'm going to have my phone with me
so I don't miss anything.
Immediately following
the service tonight, we're going to have
a chili cook-off and potluck.
It's going to be in the gym, which is the building
directly behind this building.
Don't worry if you didn't bring anything,
if this is your first time hearing about it.
Your presence there,
you being there, matters more than you bringing something.
Please, trust me when I say
we would love to have you there.
Join our family
for the night.
Check us out. Have some food.
There's plenty for everyone. We would love to have you join us
for that immediately after the service.
If you are someone
who receives SNAP benefits
and you're being affected
by the government shutdown,
please let us know.
We have
some people in our community that have generously
offered to help out others during
this time, so please
find Brett, find me, find somebody
here. You can also fill out the contact form
on our website.
Fill that out and we will get in contact with you.
We don't want anybody to go
without food.
Also, if you're available,
we have a serving
opportunity coming up at the Five Loaves
Food Pantry here in Sachse.
Make sure you sign up for that.
There's a QR code up on the screen.
That QR code is the key to everything
going on here at the table.
You can scan that and
you can find everything going on, current events,
things to sign up for, classes,
our meetups.
Go ahead
and snap that QR code.
You probably
noticed the cards that are on the
chairs, either underneath
where you're sitting or next to you.
Take a look at that.
That is something that is for you
to take with you tonight.
You can give it to a friend,
somebody who might appreciate
this community. You can put it up
on a bulletin board in your community,
maybe like a coffee shop.
You could snap a picture of it,
put it up in a Facebook group that you're a part of.
This
community is important
and it's important to
our neighbors who
are looking for a church that will
accept them completely as they
are. Sometimes
they don't know that we exist.
Why not get the word out?
Take that card with you tonight, give it to
somebody, put it up on their bulletin board,
post it online and
just share the love that we have.
If you were anxious
about being in a church setting or just
feeling a little nervous or fidgety tonight,
we have an accessibility bucket
right over there on that cabinet
with fidgets, coloring pages,
whatever you might need. You can access that
at any time. Just make sure if you take
something like a fidget,
you return it before you leave.
All right.
Let's prepare our
hearts and our minds for
worship. The candles
to my left and to my right
are a symbol of the
presence of the Holy Spirit,
Christ with us,
always there.
Quiet your mind and your
heart.
Take a deep breath.
Be here now.
Be present.
Set aside
the distractions.
Set aside the
busyness of your mind.
Take some time
to just be.
Now we exit
the kingdom of noise,
worry, and productivity.
Now we enter the
kingdom of silence,
stillness, and simplicity.
Sacred
space, a place for
prayer, worship,
and adoration.
A place to behold Christ,
revelation of God,
heartbeat of creation.
Allow the unforced
rhythms of grace to find you,
to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
Thanks,
Karen. If you guys want
to stand with us, we have a little
bit of a different setup tonight than we normally
do for those of you who are here
most Sundays. This is
our first time ever to actually use a real
piano in our worship sets, which is
funny because we've had a real piano in the room
every single meeting we've ever
had. But
there's something about coming
around a piano and singing together
and just lifting our voices
and stripping it down
this week that was just special and good
for my heart. One of the songs that we're going to
sing tonight is called Slow Me Down.
Really and truly, I feel like
that's what a piano sometimes
symbolizes for me, is
slowing down, taking
time, pausing.
Be thoughtful.
Come back to your roots
and let some of the busyness go. I hope
that tonight you can fill
that space with whatever's going on in your life.
Just let this room be
a container that's
big enough to hold all that's
coming in with you and
maybe just allow
it. Open your hands a little bit.
Allow some of it to
loosen its grip because
we have so many things pulling at us,
calling for our attention throughout
our week, and this is a time where
we get to let go a little bit, where we get
to re-center,
re-focus,
take a breath like Karen was saying.
Selah.
Let there be that space tonight as we sing
together.
You can hold
my hand
when you need to let
go.
I can be your
mountain when
you're feeling badly low.
I can
be your streetlight
showing you
the way home.
If you can hold
my hand
when you need to let
go.
I
want a house
with a crowded
table and
a place by the
fire for
everyone.
Let us
take on the world
while we're young
and able
and bring us
back together
when the day
is done.
If
we want a garden,
we're gonna
have to sow the seeds,
plant a
little happiness,
let the roots
run deep.
If it's
love that we give,
then it's love
that we reap.
If we want a garden,
we're gonna
have to sow the
seeds.
Yeah.
I want a house
with a crowded
table and
a place by the
fire for
everyone.
Let us take
on the world
while we're young
and able
and bring us
back together
when the day
is done.
The door is always
open.
Your picture's on my
wall, and
everyone's a little
broken, and
everyone belongs.
Yeah,
I
want a house
with a crowded
table and
a place by the
fire for
everyone.
Let us
take on the world
while we're young
and able
and bring us
back together
when the day
is done.
And bring us
back together
when the day
is
done.
Oh,
oh,
oh.
All right.
We're gonna dismiss the kids to go to their classes,
so you guys can meet your teachers over here
by these double doors,
and they will lead you back.
And we will see you guys afterwards
for the potluck.
We're gonna move into
the prayers of the people, and you can follow along
in the screens up
here. There will be the parts in red
that we will read aloud together,
and we'll take space in the middle for you to mention
a name or a situation that
you're carrying into this room tonight
that's on your heart, and we'll just lift those up
before God together, and then finish
the prayer.
Jesus, for this city
of Sachse, Texas, and for every city
and community and all who live
in them, we pray to
you. For the good
earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it,
we pray to you.
For the old
and the sick, for the widow
and the orphan, for the injured
and suffering, we pray
to you. For the
poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute,
for prisoners and captives,
and all who remember and care
for them, we pray
to you.
For the vulnerable,
the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race,
or other perceived difference,
we pray to you.
For those experiencing
loss, loneliness,
and disconnection, and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health, we pray to
you.
Lord, we know that you love us,
and that you hear us,
so we lift these names
and situations up to you.
♪
For the names and the moments that we have spoken
and for those that we have kept in our hearts,
we pray to you
that they may have life and
light, healing
and hope, peace,
and a deep sense of your presence.
Amen.
♪
Worthy of every song
we could ever sing
♪
Worthy of all
the praise we could
ever bring
♪
Worthy of every
breath we could ever
breathe, we live for you
♪
Jesus
the name above
every other name
♪
Jesus
the only one
who could ever save
you
Worthy of
every breath we could
ever breathe, we live
for you
♪
And holy
there is no one
like you
there is none
beside you
Open up my
eyes in wonder
and show
me who you
are and fill
me with your
heart and lead
me in your
love to those
around me
♪
Sing with me
Worthy of every
song we could ever
sing
♪
Worthy of all
the praise we could ever
breathe
♪
Worthy of every
breath we could ever breathe
we live for you
you
go
Go
, you
go
Go
slow me down
And I will build my life upon your love
It is a firm foundation
And I will put my trust in you alone
And I will not be shaken
And I will build my life upon your love
It is a firm foundation
And I will put my trust in you alone
And I will not be shaken
And holy there is no one like you
There is none beside you
Open up my eyes and wander
And show me who you are
And fill me with your heart
And lead me in your love to those around you
Lead us in your love
Follow us in your love
God would our lives begin to look different because of the one who is leading us forward
The one who is calling our name and calling us back to yourself
Back to the ways of Jesus
The one who spread his arms for us
The one who gave his life
Calling us back to the God who shaped us and formed us and knows us
The one who designed each one of us in love, in goodness
God would we be following that voice
Would our lives be led by the love that you have poured out on us
Would we look different, would we love differently
Would we live wholeheartedly into this call of Christ
That gives itself up
That finds its life when we let go of our own
When we make room for the outsider
When we look to the marginalized and meet the needs of the people around us
When we choose to forgive
When we choose to listen
God would we live as your children, fully loved and accepted
Known
We love you Jesus
Thank you for charging us with your love
Thank you for charting the path for us, for showing us the way home
For bringing us back
It's in your name that we pray all these things
Amen
You guys may be seated and could you turn to the person on your right and your left and say the peace of Christ be with you
And with you Finley
Well grace and peace
Welcome
Welcome to the table, so good to be with you all
And my name is Brett and the pastor here and yeah a joy, a joy to welcome you into this space
And as always that includes join us online, love y'all lots
And anyone here tonight who is new, if this is your first time or just your first time in a long time
Thanks for being with us and among us
And I hope you feel a sense of welcome
So also seconding what Karen mentioned, happy 6th anniversary to you all for the table
Yeah, it's a beautiful work
That God's done
And I just want to name what an honor it's been to just to walk alongside you all
And pastor here for these 6 years
It's really, yeah, it's been a joy
And it's just, I think, I don't know, maybe it's in my old age
I'm 41, I don't know, I don't know if that's old or not
I guess it's all relative
But I've been at times
Oh, poor fella
But I've been kind of reflecting on
Poor guy, I know
For all you parents out there, we've all been there
Haven't we? We've all been there, oh my God
It's tough
But, yeah, I've just been reflecting on kind of my life and my journey
And, you know, it's amazing how life unfolds
Like you literally, it's weird how, I don't know about you, I'm like a bit of a control freak in ways
So I'm always trying to like plan it out and control it and like know the future
Which, of course, I don't know
I just don't know
And it's amazing to like look back on your life at how it has unfolded
And I could not have guessed like these six years
Like the ups and the downs and the beauty
And the meaning of starting a community like this
Could not have imagined it
Like much deeper, more profound
Much richer relationally
And what God's done in my own heart
It's just like incredible
And at the same time, the challenges
Like, whoa, if God told me some of the things we might, you know, face
Whether it was the pandemic or even just the challenge of like
Kind of, you know, folks coming in and then going out
You know, as they sometimes move
And you're like, whoa, you don't realize how your heart's impacted by all that
But regardless, as I've just been kind of reflecting on my life
I look back and I really, I don't know
It's been such a meaningful thing for me
That I feel like, Lord willing, I hope I have a lot of years
But I do feel like I could die a happy man
Like, just having, you know when you just do the thing
You sense you were supposed to do
Even when it was like a little bit scary and a little bit, you know, whatever
But it's like, just do the thing
And that, I don't know, there's something in me
That is just like, oh, such a peace
So I name all that just to say
Thank you for helping to make this community possible
And just the rich, the richness and the depth that's here
Because of all of you, you know
And your openness to the Holy Spirit
And what Christ wants to do and is doing among all of us
It's just, oh, it's incredible
So let's see, we are in, we're wrapping up
We're wrapping up our series
This is the fourth, the final week in our series
The end, it's just a new beginning
And this has been one of those kind of series that we
I held off on for many years
It was like, no, I don't want to do a series on
What's known as eschatology, like the end of all things
And it just gets so weird in Christian circles
And as we'll touch on, I think apocalyptic literature
And stuff gets really misunderstood in the Bible
And so it just, you know, end times kind of stuff
Just like, ah
But what I've tried to kind of frame this up as
Is to find what I feel are the most kind of
Not only just biblically kind of faithful to the text
But also just the most beautiful vision
I can give us of the end
By the end, I don't just mean
Like literally, the world's going to burn
I mean the purpose, the telos
The end to which God is calling us and all things
And I really do believe it's an incredibly hopeful vision
So if you've been here for these weeks
You know we've been talking about the apocatastasis
The big old fancy Greek word
That just means the restoration of all things
And that's the hopeful vision
Is really that us and all creation will
Right now as Romans 8 says
We're groaning, all creation's groaning
And we look around the world
And we see that pain
And yet it's a kind of birth pain
That actually God's up to something
And there's a beautiful, healing, restorative end
For all of us
So that's what I've been kind of pressing into
Even though it's been a little bit
I know touch and go at times
Because part of that is we have to touch on the things
That are difficult
So we've talked about, what is judgment?
How do you understand judgment?
And you know, hell talk in the Bible
And you know, all that
So if you missed some of that
You can go back in previous sermons on our podcast
And catch that
But at any rate, that's kind of what we've been doing
So I thought in this message
I wanted to give it a little bit of like
The kind of catch-all
Because I realize in kind of casting that vision
There's been certain things I've kind of sidestepped
Or ignored
For example, the words antichrist
I don't think have come from my lips
Except maybe last week
Because I was referencing this coming sermon
You know, so
You know, the dragon of revelations
You know, I just haven't gotten into some of that
So I wanted to kind of in this final message
Kind of do a little bit of a catch-all
And just touch on some topics and things
Where you're like, but what about that?
Because I realize
Like this is totally a thing in Christian culture
You know, and I think some of this needs to be addressed
And kind of thought through
If you're kind of wondering like
What's Pastor Brett's thoughts on all that?
You know, end times prophecies
And you know, things like that
So that's where we're kind of going in this message
So with that in mind
The title of my message is
Resisting End Times Speculative Craziness
And not the most succinct of titles
But hopefully you get the heart of it
So what I'm going to do is
Just kind of walk us through
Four kind of, I don't know
Suggestions or four T's
To avoiding that kind of thing
And in the process hopefully
I'll touch on some of the stuff I was alluding to
So first, to avoid end times theology hot takes
Be attuned to the genre and the context of Scripture
This is very important
Where in essence we end up taking things
That are highly poetic and symbolic
And kind of allegorical in a sense
And we end up trying to like map it
Very specifically onto 21st century
You know, happenings and such
So we do this a lot with what's known
As I mentioned, apocalyptic literature
So apocalyptic, you're like, what is that?
So this is like small portions of the words of Jesus
Like Mark 13, Matthew 24, Luke 17
As well as the entire book of Revelation
And so this is when you're thinking of like
The classic kind of apocalyptic text
You know, the moon shall turn to blood
A third of the stars shall fall from the sky
You know, this kind of language
And people start to take that all quite literally
Or just get very confused
Or again try to like map it onto a certain event
If that happens, well then this will trigger
The apocalypse of this or that
And it just becomes a kind of a whole thing
So what I want to go back to
Is to kind of ground this a bit
To talk about apocalyptic literature
Like what is this?
So this style of writing
In speaking and communicating
This was like a genre
Like it kind of popped up
In what's known as the intertestamental period
So you had the 400 years
In between the ending of the Old Testament
And those writings
And the beginning of the New
And this was a time
Where for the people of God
It was somewhat of a disaster
Had a few highlights
Like if you've read some of the history
Of the Maccabees and such
Had some moments of like
Yes, we're liberated and we're free
As the Jewish people
And the people of God and all that
Mostly though it was
Empire after empire after empire
The Persians and the Greeks
And then finally the Romans
I mean it was just conquest after conquest
And so what did this do?
This starts to get
There's a cultural vibe
You've been in a culture with vibes
Like moods settle upon a people
And kind of in that
It's like they started to wrestle with
Kind of this challenge
Is this just how history is going to play out?
The people of God just struggle?
The people of God just get oppressed?
And beastly empires just have their day
And God doesn't even care?
Is that just the story
And how this is going to go?
No!
And that's where apocalyptic literature
Emerges from that culture
From that time
And in essence it was kind of a way
Of speaking about
Beast-like empires and such
Without like naming them specifically
So like for example
Most scholars believe
All but maybe the last chapters
Of the book of Revelation
Are almost certainly about the Roman Empire
That this was a way of talking about Rome
Without talking about Rome
So in essence that's an example
Where we kind of want to read into it
Like it's about America
And these little flying things
With mouths of
With sharp teeth
It's like those are helicopters
John was seeing a vision of hell
But he didn't have a language of helicopters
You know we're like whoa
We're like running with this
No probably not
Mostly this was
That's apocalyptic literature
It's this way of speaking about empire
And things going on
Without actually coming out
And just like saying it
So it's highly symbolic
And vague
But it's vague on purpose
Which is to say by the way
Not simply that
So it's just about Rome
And has no application
No it's like
I think in most ways it was about Rome
But it is
There is application
There is a kind of bridge
That can be built
To other beast-like empires
How are we the people of God
In cultures
And in at times nation states
Running amok
Or doing things that are acting
In ways that aren't in alignment
With the heart of God
And how are we to be
So I think there's
Connections there
But at the same time
We get into trouble
When we start obsessively
Trying to map everything
From that chapter
Or that book
To the 21st century
Into our own day and time
So that leads us
To the second key
We must focus on Christ
And becoming a person
Of great love
Not so much on
In time speculation
So that's where
It's sort of a matter of emphasis
Where it's like
Hey let's keep the main thing
The main thing here
For example
Throughout my life
I've had friends
I have one in particular
Who is really honestly
A godly man
Really good heart
But is very into
In time speculations
And theology and such
And he has texted me
A few times
And it's often kind of cryptic
Sometimes it will be
A link to a news article
And then a bible verse
And sometimes it's a little vague
And I'm kind of like
Okay what are you getting at
And so like for example
He sent me one time
It was
I don't remember the news article
But it was
Revelation 12
Three through four
Which says
Then another sign appeared in heaven
An enormous red dragon
With seven heads
And ten horns
And seven crowns on its head
Its tail swept
A third of the stars
Out of the sky
And flung them to earth
So he said
Red dragon
Dot dot dot
China
And I was like
Yeah
Okay so
This led to a long text message
You know where I was kind of like
Okay so here's my
Here's my problem with this
And it's kind of two
Two fold
You know whether it's
Trying to figure out the dragon
Of Revelation 12
Or who's the antichrist
Of 1 John chapter 2
Or the beast
Out of the sea
Of like Revelation 13
You know
My problem with this
Is like two fold
A
It just seems very distracting
This kind of comes back
To main point number two
Right it just seems
Distracting
It's almost like
I think Christians at times
Is it that we just get
A little bored
You know what I mean like
We're just a little bored
With like this kind of
Daily faithfulness
A life of
You know what I mean
Scripture
And contemplative prayer
And intercessory prayer
For others
And learning to love well
And you know
We're just kind of like
Okay
But I just want something
You know what I mean
And we just kind of get
Maybe it's a certain personality
I recognize not everyone
Is into this
But certain folks
Just get pulled into
Kind of the vortex
That is the
The intellectual maze
It's
There is a certain personality
As in Enneagram 5
Who's like very in my head
And just like
Think logic
Think think
Imagine
You know
Abstractions
Maybe
Honestly
Maybe in another life
I could be this person
You know
And I think we get
Pulled into that
And we just
Again
We don't keep the main thing
The main thing
We kind of lose
Our path
Where we're no longer
Really focused on
For example
How do I grow
Into loving union
With this God
Who is love
How does my heart
Get more and more
Captured by that
How do I learn
To love my neighbor
Better
You know
It's like
I don't know
I just don't get a lot of
Texts like that
Like man
Obsessed with trying
To love my neighbor
I'm just
So hard
You know
Not as interesting
Maybe
You know what I mean
But it's profound
And it's important work
But you know what I mean
We just get
Kind of pulled
Pulled into this
And in fact
You know
What can happen
And this kind of
Ties into the next thing
Which I'll mention
We might even find
That our neighbor
Who might be
Very different than us
You know
Might be Chinese
Might be Russian
Might be Muslim
Might be
You know
That all of a sudden
What's happening
They're the enemy
They're the problem
They're the
And now it's not just
A kind of distraction
From loving my neighbor
Now it's like
An act of
Like a wall
That I'm putting up
Between myself and them
Which is kind of
You know
The second kind of thing
To this focusing on Christ
Becoming a person of great love
Why do we struggle with this
Well when the symbols
Get too specific
Right
Our interpretations
Like the
The dragon is such and such
Country
You know
What happens
Well we're so focused
On the evil over there
The evil out there
Have you seen
What that country's up to
What that religion's up to
Have you seen
You know what I mean
Like
That leader
That
And we're so obsessed
With the evil out there
What are we missing
Where are we not focused
You know what I mean
Like what about me
What about my heart
What about
What about the
The beast-like
Serpent-like
Dragon-like
Stuff going on
And me
And not even just me
What about even
My community
Yeah not to put that
On you all
But you know
It would be
It would be weird
In the sense of
If we were just so obsessed
Like what if we were just
Our sermons
And our discussions
We're all about
The evils of the world
The evils of those other churches
Can you believe them
Can you believe
And we just
And it's kind of like
A weird thing
Are we thinking about us
Are we
You know what I mean
Are we kind of
Missing
Something
You know in
In kind of
Us
So to speak
Like for example
Okay take all that
Speculation right
About like the Antichrist
Which is kind of
Hinted at in
Matthew chapter 24
Verse 5
And 1st John
Chapter 2
Verse 18
You know
Who is this Antichrist
And we just get all speculative
You know what I mean
Is it him
Is it that guy
Is it that world leader
He hinted at
You know a one world government
So it must be him
And
I wonder if
You know regardless of
Whether the Antichrist
Is like some guy
Who shows up
In history
Or whatever
Which
I mean honestly
How would we
Ever know
My guess is that
As every kind of
Despot
Or every
Person arises
People of that age
You know said like
Oh it's them
They're the Antichrist
You know what I mean
We wouldn't really know
Actually until the end
Of all things
And we're like
Oh actually
Huh
I guess that was the Antichrist
You know
Like we wouldn't really know
You know what I mean
But regardless
I think we could say
To make this kind of
Helpful
Spiritually helpful
It's every tendency
Let's just make it personal
In myself
That opposes
The goodness
The beauty
The truth
Of Christ
Right
Every war against love
Within myself
You know
Maybe that should be
Our focus
You know not this guessing game
Of like
Who is the Antichrist
That just
It just so easily
Leads into this
Kind of pernicious
You know kind of a pride
And a
Spirit of accusation
And judgment
And all of that
All right
Third
point
Avoid
Avoiding
In time
Speculative
Hot takes
And craziness
The current
Huge deal
Just remember
The current
Huge deal
Whatever it is
There's always a huge deal
Maybe multiple of them
The current
Huge deal
Will not be
In one
Thousand years
I heard a preacher
Years ago
And he said
What if
Christ doesn't return
For like
Twelve thousand years
Like it was quite a thought
You know what I mean
It just gets you thinking
You know kind of like
Whoa
Okay maybe
Were you just going to do this
Like play this guessing game
For twelve thousand years
It kind of puts things
You know in perspective
And
In this sense
It's kind of easy to think
Maybe in time speculation
Like this is kind of
A modern phenomenon
But honestly
No
Not really
If you go back in
Christian and church history
And look at like Christian scholars
Or lay people
For example
The black death
That plagued Europe
In the
In the 14th century
The Christians of that day
Said
Aha
This is
One of the four horsemen
Of the apocalypse
I'm guessing they mapped it
To the black horse
You know that's my guess
Like
And
And you can see right
Where it's kind of
In that day and time
It just kind of made sense
Of like
Oh it's that
It's that
Or there was another
Example of the
The raids of the Magyar people
Into Europe
In the 10th century
They said
All the Christians
Then said
Oh it's Gog
And Magog
From Revelation
Chapter 20
Or
Martin Luther
The reformer
Very famously said
The Pope
Is the Antichrist
And the
The church
Is the whore of Babylon
Which is the language
From Revelation
And then of course
The church kind of fired back
It's like
No
We're not going to
Stop
You know
And you can
See where we just kind of
Have been doing this
For a few millennia now
And
I'm suggesting
Maybe we stop
You know
Maybe
Maybe we just stop
And say like
Huh
Is this going to age
Kind of like saying
The plague of whatever century was
You know what I mean
Is this going to age
Like the Magyar thing
And the
Is that what we're doing here
You know
Because I suspect
Probably
It will
There's a
Quote from
Sergius Bulgakov
He says this
We must remember
That the beast
And the false prophet
They're not individuals
Which is kind of
Interesting
I like this
But false principles
Of life
That have power
Over souls
And the condemnation
Refers precisely
To these
Principles
You know
That's a kind of
I don't know
There's something there
To kind of
Spiritually chew on
These
These principles
At work
There's kind of
An echo there
Of Paul in Ephesians 6
Verse 12
For our struggle
Is not against
Flesh and blood
Oh
Christians could use
That reminder
You know
And me too
Me too
But against the rulers
Against the authorities
Against the powers
Of this dark world
And against the
Spiritual forces
Of evil
And the heavenly realms
You know
You can see where
That can be helpful
Because it kind of
Takes our eyes
Quite off of this
You know
It's kind of like
Them
That person
There
That country
You know
I mean
And it
Gets us a little more
Yeah
Focused on
Maybe what the
Spirit's up to
In
In the world
And I also think
It's a better way
Of understanding
Apocalyptic literature
Right
Because it's naming
What apocalyptic
Literature is naming
It's like
Hey look
This is how evil
Can nudge
To become
Dragon-like
Serpent-like
Anti-Christ
Like
And then to admit
That I too
Can kind of be
Co-opted by these
Same
You know
Unholy
Kind of false
Principles of life
As
Bulgakov puts it
All right
Fourth and finally
Don't be
Too prisoner
Of the moment
Christ is present
And all
Shall be
Well
I'm
I'm thinking of
This point
A little bit distinct
From point number three
In the sense of
I'm thinking more
Emotionally
Now
I
I wonder if
Well
Let me come back to
Something I named
At the very beginning
Of this series
For those who were
Here in week one
Four weeks ago
I was naming
My kind of perception
Of like where
It's a clunky term
But kind of so-called
Like progressive
Christians or whatever
Which I think generally
Regardless of how
You label yourself
I think other people
Would certainly
Accept it
So I don't know
Maybe we'll just
Accept it
But kind of my
Feel for the vibe
Is that
There's a lot
Of despair
You know
Politically
Kind of on the
National stage
We have what
Kind of in my opinion
Is just a
Sort of
Borderline
Idolatrous
Fusion
Of like
Church and
Politics
In the rise of
Christian nationalism
And just to be clear
I'd be just as
Against this
If like
We're claiming
Like no, no
Our politicians
Are the very
Mouthpiece of the Lord
You know
I'd be like
Nope
You know
This is problematic
Regardless of how
You know
Whatever
So I don't want
To be overly
Partisan here
But even beyond
Our own country
You know
Well no
Let me even name
Still within the country
Also our LGBTQ
Friends and folks
Are just terrified
Right now
You know what I mean
Like it sucks
It's just the worst
Into the world
You see the devastation
In Palestine
You see the
Russian invasion
Of Ukraine
Ongoing civil war
In Sudan
I was listening to
A pod
And I actually have
Friends in South Africa
Who have been
Talking about the
I mean the awful
Crime
Hell like
People I know
Held at gunpoint
Told to
Like they have to
Tie themselves up
And threatened
With like to pour
Boiling water on them
Like just
The worst
You know
And I was like
Man the world
Is just trembling
In all directions
And in that kind of
Climate
It's just very easy
You know
To just be like
Gah
It's a little bit
Of how the Jewish people
Felt when apocalyptic
Literature rose
You know what I mean
Like is this just
Is this just how it is
Like ah just
Silent and
What's up
You know we just
All stumble along
And
Ah
You know it's
It's very
Depressing and like
Difficult time
And yet I just
I think of John 1633
Which doesn't say
Hey if you follow me
Everything is just
Going to get better and better
You're going to have
You know smooth sailing
No he says this
In this world
You will have trouble
Okay
Um
In this world
You will have trouble
But what
But take heart
Take heart
I've overcome
The world
Right this is
This is the
This is the restoration
Of all things
Like
We can't be um
Too prisoner of the moment
Only seen
And kind of captured
Emotionally by like
The present
And this is what's going on
And this is everything
You know
We got to kind of
Zoom out a little bit
And find some hope
Find some hope
Um
I think of
Julian of Norwich
The great Christian mystic
Put it this way
All shall be well
In all manner
Of things
Shall be well
I think that's
Hard for us
You know
Um
Partly because
Julian
She's drawing here
From a
Well she's had an experience
Of God
And a kind of
Settledness in her own soul
Where she just knows
Like oh
Okay
It's going to be okay
All shall be well
Um
I think the trick is
You know
We kind of hear a quote
Like that
And it's just theology
You know I mean
It's just ideas
Intellectual ideas
That are on the screen
And it's kind of like
Well I disagree
You know
I don't know
Of all shall be well
I mean
I don't know
Of all shall be well
But it's
Um
I mean this is where
We kind of have to get
A little bit
Out of the head
And kind of
Sinking down into the heart
And to do some
Inner work here
Where we start to really
Connect with Christ
To where we know
Again not just as
Some sort of
Intellectual idea
Oh okay
All shall be well
And I just need to believe that
You know but like
Meditate on that
Take that in
And let that kind of sink in
To where we actually
Have a kind of taste of God
You know
Come taste and see
The Lord is good
And then it like
Comes for us
You know what I mean
Like deep in the
In the soul
Um
And I
I wonder
Do you
Do you know anyone like this
Like in your life
Do you know someone
Who is just kind of that
Like settled
Like a kind of anchor
Like
I'm thinking of a Christian
They're probably like
Later
Second half of life for sure
Maybe fifties
Sixties
Seventies
Um
You know any Christians like this
Who
They're just not quite blown around
So much by the
The shifting sands
Of the latest news cycle
And the
Do you know anyone like this
If you do
Treasure them
You know like
Oh my
And
Seek as best you can
By God's grace
To become them
You know what I mean
Like ask them
What are you doing
How do you
How do you grow in that
Because I really believe
Like
Right now we need Christians
Badly
Who are like rooted
And grounded
In
Christ
And who have done some of that
That inner work
To find a certain
Peace
Where
Even while we can say
Everything is a mess
And yet at the same time
And all shall be well
You know
All shall be well
Um
Kind of in closing
I want to
Give you kind of four ways
Maybe to
To do that
To kind of wrap up the series
And if you're wondering
Like still
That's a little abstract
How might you live into this
So just four suggestions
For how we can live this out
First
Stay grounded in love
Not in speculation
Um
Right when you find yourself
Kind of tempted
To match headlines
With Bible verses
Maybe try instead
To just match your daily life
You know
With Jesus' way of great love
And uh
Because the end
That Christ really cares about
It's not about like
Charts and codes
And numerology
Or something
Uh
It's really I believe
About compassion
It's about forgiveness
Um
It's uh
About peacemaking
And hospitality
Second
And this is really practical
Just practice a bit
Of silence
And stillness
We had some of that tonight
Uh
As Karen kind of
Invited us into it
And our worship team
Um
I really think
Like this is so needed
In um
Our kind of own
Cultural moment
We're so busy
And frazzled
I mean it's no wonder
We're like
No all shall not be well
You know I mean like
We just
Because we're
We don't even feel it
On the inside
You know so I really
Encourage you
Just take some space
And be quiet
Uh
Um
And kind of a method
Or way of doing that
You can look up um
Or talk to me about
Centering prayers
A kind of Christian form
Of prayerful meditation
And silence
I think it's very
Wonderful and powerful
Um
So anyway that's one
Kind of practical thing
Third
Anchor your hope
In Christ's character
Not the world's chaos
Right
It's so easy to kind of
Um
Place our hope
In kind of like
Politics
And headlines
Or even just
Personal circumstances
And things going well
You know
And uh
Our true hope though
Is actually in the steady
Unchanging love of God
A love that will have
The final word
So don't try and find
Security in those
Shifting sands
Of uh
The world around you
Sink deeply
In the love of God
Fourth and finally
Join God's renewal
Right
Now
You know
For some
The Christian faith
As we touched on last week
Is all about
Like
Avoiding the bad
Hell
Avoidance
Some people even have
A little term for this
Uh
Like the term of like
Christian
You know it's just
That's what Christianity
Is all about
Do you want to go to the bad place?
Of course you don't
Well then believe in Jesus
You know
This is like
The framing of like
The whole faith
It's just that
Uh
I completely disagree with this
I think
Like
This isn't um
About avoiding
God's supposed bad side
Which is bad
Doctrine
Um
Instead
This is what we've been
Talking about
Right
This is sinking
Into the love of God
So
Live into
And be faithful
To the Holy Spirit's invitation
To actually
Bring about
A kind of
All shall be well
Reality
You know
To start to live into
This new creation
Yes all creation's groaning
But there's gonna come
A day of its redemption
And the whole idea
Of being a Christian
Is we like
Just get little
Inbreakings of this
We have little snapshots
Of it
We have little moments
Even this community
Is supposed to be
A little like
Picture of new creation
Of love
And kindness
So let's not give into despair
Um
Let's
Let's live into it
Uh
Because in the end
I really do believe
Christ is here
Love wins
And uh
Truly all shall be well
In the name of the Father
The Son
And the Holy Spirit
Amen
So
On the night Jesus was betrayed
He had one final meal
With his disciples
And at that meal
He held up a loaf of bread
And he broke it
He said
Take this
Eat
This is my body
It's broken for you
And he said
Take this
Drink
This is my blood
It's shed for you
Whenever you eat this bread
Whenever you drink this cup
Remember me
And so that's the
The sacrament
As we come forward
That's what we're participating in
This connection
With Christ
That we need so badly
To ground us in
In his great love
Uh
The way we'll participate
In communion tonight
Is we'll just go
Row by row
Starting here at the front
And we'll just form one line
Here in the middle
So when one row's done
The next one can jump up
And uh
Kind of get in line
And you can have
Like a little open table
So if you're here tonight
And you'd like to participate
Regardless of your exact
Denominational background
Or whatever
Um you're free to
Come forward if you'd like to
At the same time
There's no pressure
If you'd rather not
That's okay
Um to just know
The red is wine
The white is grape juice
And finally
You can just partake
Whenever and however
You'd like
Some people come
Kneel at the front
Some partake immediately
Um but no one will lead you
Through the exact moment
Of partaking
So this is the table
Not at the church
But at the Lord
And it's made ready
For those who love Him
And for those who want
To love Him more
So come
You who have much faith
And you who have little
You who have been here often
And you who have not been here long
You who have tried to follow
And you who have failed
Come
Come because it's the Lord
Jesus Himself
Who invites you
And it's His will
That those who want to meet Him
Should meet Him here
Come to the table
Thank you
You who have faith
And you who have not been here long
You who have tried to follow
And you who have failed
Come
Come because it's the Lord
Jesus Himself
Who invites you
And it's His will
That those who want to meet Him
Should meet Him here
Come to the table
Thank you
You who have faith
And you who have not been here long
You who have tried to follow
And you who have failed
Come because it's the Lord
Jesus Himself
Who invites you
And it's His will
That those who want to meet Him
Should meet Him here
Come to the table
Thank you
You who have faith
And you who have not been here long
You who have tried to follow
And you who have failed
Come because it's the Lord
Jesus Himself
Who invites you
And it's His will
That those who want to meet Him
Should meet Him here
Come to the table
Thank you
You who have faith
And you who have not been here long
You who have tried to follow
And you who have failed
Come because it's the Lord
Amen
Thank you
Treat
I don't know how many of you recognize the names Phillips, Craig and Dean
But let it take you back
Let it take you back tonight, alright?
The words of this song have always been just so beautiful to me
And Brett and I were talking about it a ways back
About like, oh we need to do this prayer at some point during the service
And it felt very fitting, he brought it up to me during this series
And was like, that is such a good encapsulation of like our heart
As we talk about apocatastasis
Did I nail it? I did it?
I practiced that this week you guys
Apocatastasis, as we talk about the restoration of all things
And where our hearts want to go as we look towards the future
But also towards today and Christ being in our midst
And being with us
And grounding us in today even as we look forward
This song just felt like such an appropriate prayer
So I hope you guys can just receive this tonight as we wrap up our series
Lord, let your light
Light of your face
Shine on us
Lord, let your light
Light of your face
Shine on us
That we may be saved
That we may have light
To find our way
In the darkest night
Let your light shine on us
Lord, let your grace
Grace from your hand
Fall on us
Lord, let your grace
Grace from your hand
Fall on us
That we may be saved
That we may have light
To find our way
In the darkest night
Let your grace fall on us
Lord, let your love
Love with no end
Come over us
Lord, let your love
Love with no end
Come over us
That we may be saved
That we may have light
To find our way
In the darkest night
Let your love come over us
Let your light shine on us
Thank you.
Mandy, Caitlin, Maggie,
what a beautiful worship set
and last songs.
Amazing.
Oh, we're so blessed.
Thank you so much.
We're so blessed
by your presence as well.
Those of you who are here
and I know we have some people
tuning in online tonight
because you guys were texting me
and I just wanna send some love
out to all of you as well.
If you are new here,
thank you for being with us.
If you would,
we would really love it
if you fill out a visitor card.
You can do that
by scanning the QR code
that will be up on the screens
or you can fill out a card
on the table right over there.
Don't forget,
we have our chili cook off
and potluck happening
immediately after.
Even if you didn't bring anything,
please don't let that stop you.
We would love to have you join us
and be a part of that,
celebrate our sixth anniversary
of being the table.
What else?
Oh, the potluck will be in the gym
and if you don't know where that is,
just go out these doors,
through the lobby,
down the long hallway,
just follow the people.
You will find it
or ask someone.
We'll make sure you find it.
If you believe in the good work
that's happening here at the table,
please consider giving financially.
This thing can't happen
without everybody's time,
energy and resources
and we want to be around
for a long, long time.
Please give if you are able.
It really does help expand
the work that's happening here
and beyond.
You can do that, again,
QR code or you can go to our website,
thetabletx.org.
All right, my favorite part.
If you are able,
please stand to your feet.
I would love to send you out
into the week ahead
with this benediction.
You can hold your hands out
just as a symbol of receiving
or just open your heart
to these words
that I believe are true
for each and every one of you.
You are a child of God.
This is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined
highs and lows
and everything in between,
go filled with the assurance
that you are loved,
you are worthy
and you are accepted
just as you are.
And go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend
these same gifts of love,
grace and compassion
to everyone you come in contact with
this week.
Be blessed and we'll see you
in a few minutes for the potluck.
Good night.
♪♪♪♪
♪ That we may be saved,
that we may have might
to find our way
in the darkest night.
Let Your love come over us.
Let Your light shine on us.
♪♪♪♪♪
♪♪♪♪